Richard Christie he's disgusting he was
telling me this morning that he drinks
this coffee and he says it's made from
Beans
picked from the feces of a rat-like
creature called a civet and I go dude is
that for real are you drinking why would
he do that you're drinking something
that came out of a rat's ass seriously
no I mean really it's the best coffee
I've ever had in my life Howard but it's
not coffee it's [__] well they think
they wash it Robin I would hope but you
wash it it becomes coffee it doesn't
become coffee Robin if you eat some
coffee beans and [__] them out I would
probably drink the coffee from those
beans well I'll do that I'll do that for
a bit I'll tell you what I'll eat some
coffee beans and [__] them out and
actually drink it Howard why not do it
let's do it I swear I want to try it
because if it's half as good as this rat
[__] coffee then I'm all for it I don't
know let me tell you if you drink coffee
beans that came out of my ass it would
taste like gold pal let me tell you that
I'm telling you is it true that you gave
some to Sal and you told him afterwards
that it was to [__] from an animal and
he got so mad yeah really messed up
yeah Richard's like hey buddy you gotta
try this coffee it's amazing and I took
a sip I go wow this is really great
coffee and he goes yeah it's rat [__]
and I'm like are you I'm like a kid like
I just thought he was joking he goes no
it's really and he he shows me on Google
with the rats [__] it out and I I
was so like why would you do that to me
yeah Steve nowicki was telling me he
drinks that he was drinking it for two
weeks didn't know it was ratchet or made
from this [__] and uh but now he still
drinks it he says it's so good he's my
coffee drinking buddy at the office I'm
like Steve let's go get a rat [__]
coffee and we get one every time we're
at the office where do you find it who's
give it a Starbucks selling that now no
you find it when you find it behind a
dumpster Robin the rats taking a [__] if
the guy puts it in a cup you drink this
ratchet coffee too yeah I was drinking
it for two weeks and then I'm like I
wonder what this is and we googled what
the beans look like and I'm like that
kind of looks like [__] and Richard's
like it is [__] he's like I've had beer
made out of that [__] too it's so good
yeah I had a beer made from the same
beans from the rat [__] years ago it was
a coffee beer and it was one of the best
beers I've ever had too and it made
sense because it's a very gritty kind of
coffee so once I learned that I can like
taste it in my teeth but then I was like
I've been enjoying for two weeks so why
am I gonna stop at this point Richard
loves anything [__] like I should just
[__] in Richard's mouth and he'll be
happy
oh it's got to be filtered so anything
[__] I mean that's how the next
pandemic's gonna start from Richard
you're drinking [__] Howard I'm serious
about picking some beans out of your
[__] and trying the coffee I'll do that
okay I'll do it I'll shoot out some
beans sure I bet you'll love it
Filter Hey I like Howard [__] coffee
you truly are a [__] yeah stop
talking [__] about my coffee
thank you